[Music]
good morning Hank it's Thursday good
morning John
that's the big surprise that's a big
surprise it's still us still the two of
us just kidding there's another surprise
well I think a good surprise is that
we're doing a video together yeah
actually so it's not really good morning
Hank good morning John it's more good
morning nerdfighters that was cool yes
completely not we're on fire we didn't
even Skype that that was so improvised
today's video comes in two parts first
we are going to answer some frequently
asked questions and secondly we are
going to talk about the exciting secret
project Hank
I can't tell the two of you apart which
one is which I'm John I'm Hank
not Yeti why do they call her the Yeti
John it's because she's so hairy Hank
she is so hairy oh my god is amazing
it's all over her face I would hate like
to clean your drains why is there an I'm
missing and communication in the
animated intro it's because there is no
I on brotherhood but why is there no I
in communication um because there's no I
and shut the pub I want to become a
nerdfighter how do you put an intern
fighter uh if you want to become a
nerdfighter you probably already are
nerdfighter technically you should go to
brotherhood to comm and write a song but
in all likelihood you my friend are a
nerdfighter and like three months ago
that would have sucked but now it's
awesome somehow how do you become a
secret sibling to become a secret
sibling I have to do is make a video
response to one of our videos on YouTube
preferably several responses in a row
every day remember like in January you
guys said that you gotta make a happy
dance compilation yeah let her have it
of that we didn't do it um I don't know
if you've noticed this Hank but there's
like 70 million abandoned brotherhood
2.0 projects along the way I mean
question Tuesday question Tuesday my
sister's they didn't even have a second
appearance just the UM cuesta giving
away of my tote bags but there is
another aunt
to this question and that brings us to
the exciting secret project which is
about not to be secret anymore notice
how I didn't split the infinitive John
and I are asking the nerdfighters to
help us create the happy dance project
Hank and I were sitting around the other
day and we said to each other you know
it would be more awesome than if we made
a happy dance compilation video if all
of the nerdfighters sent us their happy
dances dancing in front of their awesome
places in their towns and neighborhoods
and then we made a happy dance
compilation video using all nerdfighter
happy dances because you know that
nerdfighters have a lot of crazy happy
dances I mean we've seen some happy
dances and some secret sibling videos
crazy happy dances I mean these videos
are so crazy and sexy and cool they
could be a TLC album word excellent use
of word some quick rules about the happy
dance videos we hope you'll send us
please make them about 10 seconds long
not too much longer because otherwise
our computers will explode also please
send them to sparks fly up at gmail.com
you probably need a deadline I know you
people you like to procrastinate October
1st October 1st at the very latest but
if you have your Halloween costumes
already put them on it would be great if
everyone could organize to make sure
that there's a happy dance in front of
like the 7 major one wonders of the
world so if we could have someone hit
the Hanging Gardens of Babylon that
would be very helpful because we are
gonna have a tough time getting to
Babylon you might have wanted to choose
one of the major one over the world that
still exists get to the pyramids oh by
the way if you're new to this and
wondering what a happy dance is it's the
dance that you do when you're incredibly
happy here's two examples see now is way
less than 10 seconds there fires a telly
roll